It's a pleasure for me to be back once
again in pace for the
second pis international sunnah
convention. The first was held last year
in January and the theme of this year's
convention is Al Quran the divine
guidance and the topic of my talk is Al
Quran the last and final revelation from
God. Al Quran is the last and final
revelation which was revealed to the
last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. It's
mentioned in the Quran in surah chapter
number 35 verse number
24. There is not a nation or a tribe to
whom you have not sent a warner. It's
mentioned surah chapter number 13 verse
number
7 in every nation have we sent a guide
by name. There are
messengers mentioned in the
Quran. Adam, Noah, Abraham, Moses,
Jesus, Muhammad, peace be upon them all.
By name 25 messengers have been
mentioned in the glorious Quran. And if
you read the hadith of the prophet, it's
mentioned in Mishkat al- Masabi that
there were 124,000 messengers sent on
the face of the earth. But by name only
25 are mentioned in the Quran. All the
messengers that came before the last and
final messenger, Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him, they were meant only for a
particular group of people. And the
message which they bought, the
revelation that came was only meant for
a particular time period. But because
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
the last and final messenger. He was not
sent only for the Muslims or the Arabs.
He was sent for the whole of humanity.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah
amyia chapter number 21 verse number
107 mean that we have sent thee not but
as a mercy to all the worlds as a mercy
to all the nations as a mercy to the
whole of humanity. Because prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was the last
and final messenger. He was not sent
only for the Muslims or for the Arabs
but for the whole of humanity. And Allah
says in Sabah chapter number 34 verse
number
28 that we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving glad tidings
and warning them against sin. But most
of the human beings yet do not know.
Allah says in the Quran in surah the
chapter number 13 verse number 38
Had in every age have you sent a
revelation in every age Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala has revealed a book by name
only four are mentioned in the Quran
Torah Zabur injil and the Quran tora was
the revelation which was revealed to
Moses peace be upon him zabur was the
wahi the revelation which was revealed
to David daisam peace be upon him and
injil was the revelation the which was
revealed to Jesus peace be upon him and
the glorious Quran is the last and final
revelation which was revealed to the
last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him all the
revelation that came four I mentioned my
name but there are many others for
example SFA Ibrahim etc but all the
revelation that came before the last and
final revelation they were meant for a
particular group of people and the
message was supposed to be followed for
a particular time period. It wasn't till
eternity. But because the glorious Quran
is the last and final revelation from
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala revealed to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. It was
revealed for the whole of humanity.
Allah says in surah Ibrahim chapter
number 14 verse number one alif lamra.
This is a revelation revealed to G
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him so
that he may guide humankind from
darkness to light. It's mentioned in
surah Ibrahim chapter number 14 verse
number 52. Here is a message for
mankind. Let them take warning there
from let them know there's one God. Let
the men of understanding take heed. It's
mentioned in surah bakar chapter number
two verse number 85. Ramadan is the
month in which the glorious Quran was
revealed as a guide to humanity as a
criteria for humankind to judge right
from wrong. It's mentioned in surah
Zomar chapter number 39 verse number 41
that we have revealed to the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him the Quran so
that he may instruct the humankind not
only the Muslims the Arabs but the whole
of humankind. So the glorious Quran
because it is the last and final
revelation from Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala to the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. It
was not revealed only for the Muslims or
the Arabs. It is revealed for the whole
of humanity.